To help me situate this let's look
at image transformations in general.
So far we have looked
at image filtering.
Now what we're going to talk about is
image warping or image transformation.
So here basically assume
we have an image,
f, and what we're interested in doing
is some sort of a transformation.
So for example,
what we have looked at is we have
transformed this image to a new one,
and here, hopefully you can see that
this image is now much brighter.
If you remember where
we've looked at before,
one of the best ways of doing this would
be to look, loop over the entire image,
and look at each and every intensity,
and perhaps do some calculations to it.
In this one, I just added, let's say,
20 more intensity points to it.
Now of course this image is brighter.
Here now,
let's do another form of transformation
to get the output image g.
Here, if you notice what we've done,
is we've actually now
stretched out the image.
So if you look at this
number of columns here,
there are more number of columns here.
Of course, so
far the same number of rows.
So in essence,
we've changed the width of the image,
keeping the height the same.
So in the case of doing filtering, what
we're basically doing is we're changing
the range of the image, the inside
values of the function itself.
So basically to get the output image,
what we basically have done is done
put in a function and transformed the
function itself to get the new image.
In case of changing the size of
the image and such, what we're basically
changing is the number of things
like rows and columns, the insight.
Not the content, but the indexes
of the matrix that we're changing.
To do this, of course,
we basically are now growing
a transformation of the insides.
That is the width and the height and all
of the information associated with it.
And that's changing the function.
So the transformation of course in
this one image is the change of
domain of the image as opposed
to change of range of the image.
Those of you curious about these terms,
I encourage you to look back
to your old calculus or
algebra material on defining what is
a range and domain of a function.
And, of course,
here our function is always at image.